well Matthew will congratulations the
two of you have proven your skills and
are joining us in the third and final
round of this kitchen themed competition
over the past two rounds you both built
a small CHF knife in the next four days
we're up in the Annie and asking you
both to build a slightly more
intimidating blade for The Culinary
World BL Miss we want you to build
this the hog splitter good luck we'll
see you both in 4 days let's
go
I've never made a weapon this big before
the challenge is drawing it so wide and
so far out I'm starting with 36 layers
of 1095 and 15
and20 I have some RW iron around here
I'm going to do deasus sand M and it's
going to look awesome it looks
beautiful I've got the RW iron all drawn
out it's time to get our full Billet
together
[Music]
looking good looks like I needed about
another inch for my width it's going
pretty smooth now that we're forged to
length and width it's time to grind the
profile and get a shape on this blade
I'm starting to see a few little
inclusions on the
spine getting cracks is one of the worst
things that could happen to a blade of
this size when the judges go to test it
it would definitely fail I'm at the edge
of my parameters right now so I don't
want to grind any F farther so I'm just
going to fill it with Weld and make it
solid I'm happy with this result
hopefully we can make it through testing
yesterday we got a quench done and then
I painted a bear paw with nail polish so
when I etch this when I clean off the
nail polish it will leave the negative
image on bare steel first thing I'm
going to do this morning is clean off
that nail polish I want to see that
maker Mark pop looks great it's time to
get the handle ready
it's the end of day four this thing is
awesome it is sharp it is Sleek I can't
wait to see it cut I'm happy as hell
right
now my plan is to make this hog splitter
out of Sanai Damascus with a core of ad
crv2 I set up my Damascus Billet and I
Chuck it in the Forge oh my God dear God
it's
heavy I am starting to get a little
worried because it's just such a hard
material it's just so much to
move the Billet is an inch and a half
wide I'm aiming for a 4 and 1/2 in wide
blade so I clean it up and then restack
and triple my layer count I still have
to draw out this hog splitter to
size it's just taking forever
carbon steel is really really hard it
feels like pounding on a
rock I am worried that I just won't have
enough width in my blade to make this
work and to meet
parameters I thought I had enough but I
don't time is
limited so I decide to weld a 1-in piece
of bar onto the spines that I meet withd
parameters
I am just praying that when I put it in
the oil it doesn't Bend or
work it is straight nothing seems to
have cracked I'm feeling tentatively
triumphant I have a fully hardened blade
I just need to put the rest of my handle
on at sharpen and put an animal on it I
go for a DCH and it's beautiful it's not
as bright as I I'd like but you can't
have everything in this world I need to
engrave a dragon into this thing I'm
carving a dragon because they're kind of
my signature one of the things that I
teach and that stands out about my
classes is that we always finish by
making a silly little dragon
face now I can get to my fit and finish
work it looks really good and it feels
really good in the hand I can yes I'm
done welcome to the kill
test in keeping with our culinary theme
I'm going to take your hog splitter and
try to use it like a butcher to split
this hog in half Willow you're up first
you ready for this let's go full hog I
want to curl up into a ball all I can
think about is will it
cut
all right will let's talk about your hog
splitter here first up the overall look
kind of unique I like that point at the
tip over there it kind of gives it a
different look holding on to it was nice
and smooth and with a very heavy topl
loaded blade I can control even with
light cuts to make sure that I can spit
a whole hog in half and overall your hog
spitter beautiful
ke Matthew you're up you ready do your
worst all right going into this test I
am close to myself it was a heck of a
huge weapon to build that's definitely
had some struggles but it's awesome I
love looking at this
[Music]
thing gentlemen uh this does not look
like it's within parameters it looks
small or what do you guys think had to
be at least four yeah four in through
the entire it has to be a minimum of
four just find
out what are we at he's at least in
eighth of been short eighth to a quarter
short all the way through so it's the
parameter fill mhm
[Music]
yeah all right Matthew we got a bit of
an issue with this blade we had a series
of parameters one of which was that it
should not be any less than 4 in
throughout the entirety of the blade and
it seems that you did not meet that Mark
so this is considered a parameter
failure we want to say thank you for
coming out you're clearly a talented
Smith but unfortunately your time in
this competition is ended I'm going to
have to ask you to please step off the
forge floor before I ground my Edge I
knew I was darn close to get parameter
and I must have just gone a little B too
small it is what it is but overall this
experience was awesome I would
definitely do this again if I was
invited
back well will congratulations that
makes you a fortun fire Champion you'll
be receiving a check for $10,000 I had
an absolute blast I have learned so much
I'm like 20 times the bladesmith I was
even a week
ago thank you creative work give you a
hug I know you're very big and scary but
can I hug you I'm not very big well
you're bigger than me all right
[Music]
sure